don't get too caught up in in making a
plan if that's not the kind of person
that you are
but if you are uh very meticulous and
very planned yeah that can work too
welcome to 20-minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
[Music]
this episode is powered by jventures a
community driven vc found in silicon
valley
in partnership with lomi tech and
sponsored by hippo insurance
touring opposed labs and hillel at
stanford navigating through life's
different decisions is very very
difficult
welcome idosarig chief marketing officer
at indigo.ai
ido is a product marketing and corporate
development executive and former vc
he was the general manager of the
internet of things group at wind river
and the vp of product marketing for its
testing business unit
earlier he was the cmo of bdna and
before that a partner with thomas weasel
venture partners
where he focused on enterprise software
he began his career with mercury
interactive as a vp of product marketing
and the vp of technology strategy
thank you for joining me on 20 minute
leaders how are you today
i'm doing great michael thank you very
much for having me
i'm excited to have you all the way from
palo alto right now
all the way from palo alto at the moment
although
later in the year hopefully uh from the
east coast where i'm going to be
relocating
to be a little bit closer to my
daughters who are going to college on
the east coast
wonderful you know it's such a
phenomenal career in so many different
places
and primarily in the world of of product
marketing corporate development
you know transitioning through different
types of companies in the tech sphere
most recently
doubling down on on ai companies and
both
early stage you know as board member and
advisor but also late stage with the vc
stint in the middle so a lot to be
discussed here
and but what i really like to start with
is a little bit about yourself a little
bit about
you know the way you go through your
career and how you went through your
career
and some of the insights that now in
retrospect
you're able to say okay now now i
understand sort of the
you know the big ideas of why i did what
i did all right that's that's an actual
uh starting point i think you know if
you wanted me to describe
how i went about uh my career
um i think a not unfair characterization
would be to call it
half hazardous um in the sense that
it wasn't fully planned um i think
broadly speaking when i look at friends
and colleagues in the industry
if i want to pay with very broad brush
strokes there are
two kinds of people there are people who
are very well
organized pre-planned they knew already
when they graduated
high school exactly what they want to do
and they had they set a goal for
themselves and a typical goal
was i'm going to start my own company
where i'll be the ceo
and um you know ideally i'll take it
public or
sell it for a nice exit but in order to
get to that point
there are a number of milestones that i
need to uh
to accomplish i need to maybe get a good
technical education at a good school
and then i need to get a job in one of
the high tech companies
um in an engineering role or some other
technical role
and then i need to get an mba from a
good business school
and then branch out with my own company
and so on and so forth um i was never
like sounds like a great player
it sounds like a great plan and i do
know quite a few people who were able to
follow that plan
uh to the t almost um
some of them came to me during certain
points in my career to ask for advice
about what's the next step
and honestly i could only usually give
them guidance about what is the next
immediate step because i myself
do not belong to that group of people i
was um
not quite so uh well planned the only
thing i knew when i was going
when i went to high school was that i
liked computers
and i thought i might want to do
something related to computers so when i
finished my army service
i went to the technion and
my initial thoughts were i was going to
do computer science
but macroeconomic factors at the time
this was
israel was going through a very serious
downturn in the software industry
impacted by the cancellation of the levy
project and so on
and there was um a lot of uncertainty
about future job prospects for software
engineers
so just in order to yeah it's hard to
think it's hard to imagine that today
right but those are the other days to
say that you know i'm going to
university now and it's you know it's
all it almost feels like you know when i
even talk to middle schoolers
they already know exactly know what they
want to do with computers in what world
and what industry and what they
and and what they want to study with
that and it's hard for me to imagine a
world where you're saying you know
i i want to be a soccer engineer but i
don't know if that's the best thing for
me i don't know if that's
going to get me a good job later on
exactly so just in order to
increase my job prospects i ended up the
technion had just recently opened
this joint uh force project where you
could get a degree in computer
engineering that
you know i got into the uh computer
science uh
the faculty of computer science but it
also required you to take a lot of more
hardware courses in conjunction with the
electrical engineering and i thought you
know
that's just hedge our bets have some
hard work component
in that um but it was not done because i
i love
hardware so much um i still don't um
don't get me wrong i think that it was a
very valuable education and i think it
did give me
um a leg up on some uh
other people and i'll tell you a funny
little anecdote that relates to that
in a moment um but i didn't do it
because i wanted to be
involved uh with hardware i did it to
increase job prospects and as it turned
out by the time i graduated things had
turned around and there was plenty of
software jobs in israel and
i never looked back the funny anecdote
is
i think a lot of people who
go through very academic-focused
computer science uh curriculum
don't really get a firm grasp on what
the computer is
underneath um we had while i was working
at mercury
um many many years ago uh we
we were developing a product called uh
initially it was called
the product i was working on was called
xrunner which was a
functional regression testing tool uh
for the x windows system
most of your listeners probably have no
idea what i'm talking about these days
i barely have an idea what are you
talking about it was the precursor to
very
to modern windowing systems like windows
but it was running on on the unix uh
operating system and we had just started
uh
porting it creating a version of it for
windows um
and we developed a product called
windrunner which was the equivalent
for the uh microsoft windows system and
we were working on a product for uh os2
yes there was something like that
those way back then um and also
uh for the mac and along comes
a recent college graduate who shall
rename
uh nameless and which was assigned
she was assigned to work on this uh
macrunner project
and a couple of weeks into her job
she comes and she talks to her manager
and she said you know i really don't
understand um why we're putting all this
work into the supporting why can't we
just
take the code that is currently running
on this pc and you know you
take uh copy it over and put it on the
mac and we'll run on the mac won't it so
just a fundamental misunderstanding of
the underlying computer architecture
admittedly this is a an outlier case i
don't mean to disparage uh
computer science academics in any way
but i do think that the
hardware um having this understanding of
the hardware was very important
um is it as important today do you think
to have that core that foundational
understanding because i think that that
speaks a lot to
you know these growing trends saying you
know maybe academia is not for everybody
maybe you don't need to know the ins and
outs
and the zeros and ones maybe you're
you're you're good enough to just know
the really high level
uh the high level standards to be able
to
to just you know code the regular things
we see in our day-to-day how relevant
is that information do you think today
okay i think it's two two separate
questions
one is uh the relevance of academia and
the second one is the heart
the hardware question i think it's still
important but it's less important
i think the industry has evolved to a
point where there is
a level of abstraction and a level of
pre-built
reusable components especially if you're
doing cloud development
that you could come up with a great idea
and implement it using high-level
structures without having
to ever worry about the underlying
infrastructure so it's less important
than it used to be
it's important for the people who build
uh this infrastructure of course
but if you're talking about building uh
an application or
cloud-based service it's far less
important
the academia question is is interesting
um most of the people i've worked with
in my career
had had formal academic training
right yes or double e graduates
and i do think there is a lot to be said
for having
formal training
in academic disciplines i see that
especially
um as my daughters
go to school now in the us
they they
are not directly following in their
father's footsteps i'll say
um they both are pursuing
an undergraduate degree in a liberal
arts college and when i went on
college tours with them part of joining
um honestly those uh
the the tours rubbed me the wrong way
but
yeah they did um for several reasons um
one is broadly speaking you've seen one
you've seen them
all and so after the fifth one
added up to here because they're all
saying the same things right
and this is true not just for liberal
arts colleges it's true
across the board um whether you go to a
large
public research university or a small
liberal arts college
i i can give you the tour for a generic
college right now
you can uh if you come here and
here only you can uh design your own
design your own major if we don't have
one for you you we have
2 000 different clubs and if there's one
that you uh
don't like you can create your own we do
study abroad
they're all exactly the same but um
having said that
i do think that they have one thing
right which is
they if they do their job properly
they give the kids a good tool set with
which they could do
anything so in my current role right now
i'm looking to hire
a uh an intern for a research project
with
which has to do with uh looking at a
company's
mission statements and purpose
statements and so on and analyzing them
in
different ways and i'm about to hire
a liberal arts uh
college student who's studying
german studies it has absolutely nothing
to do with
uh technology or computer but
impressed me in terms of her the skills
that she uh
picked up uh at this very good school
that she's going to
um and it really doesn't matter so
there's a strong current right now um
driven by
people like peter thiel and others that
says you don't need to get a college
degree come here i'll give you a hundred
thousand dollars work on your idea
and i think that could work
but i think the people that are coming
out of academia uh
tend to be more rounded and yes well you
could certainly learn how to
program in python very easily online and
for free doing a coursera course and if
you've got
a natural inclination
or talent for that that sort of thing
you could become a very good programmer
but i don't think becoming a very good
entrepreneur is synonymous with being a
very good programmer
right or i think even engineer right i
mean but what encapsulates engineering
it's much
it's like much more beyond just this
idea of you know learning how to code
it's about problem solving and it's
about being exposed to all these
different problem sets
and i think i have to admit that before
i went to go and begin my studies
at my institution i was very skeptical
of whether it makes sense for me to even
go study you know i served for five
years in the idf
in the cyber security unit which in
itself is considered a university to
many
and at the same time now after almost
two years in my institution
i just realized how how amazing it is
and how
how mind opening it is to be exposed to
just these different problems even if
they don't
that are not necessarily relevant to my
later day-to-day life just being exposed
to them
and allowing myself to immerse in them
and to think critically about how i
would go about solving them
i think it really trains me into
bringing that open mind to the n plus
one problem that that inevitably will
solve as engineers and entrepreneurs
later on you know i'd love to hear also
a little bit about you know
your take as you go through these
organizations making an impact whether
it's through product marketing or
our or corporate development tell me a
little bit about what
drives you in these companies when you
enter a new company or in an existing
company
how do you actually see your scope of
work and how do you you know measure
your own
you know productivity or your own you
know milestones making sure that you're
doing the best that you can do
an excellent question um i'll
tackle the last question first i'm a
very
um results oriented person and
ultimately
the way i measure my impact or my team's
impact
is against uh pre-established rules what
did we say we
were going to do and to what degree did
we meet them and to what degree did we
meet them
on time um that is primary i think
that's
different though from the question you
initially thought which is when you go
into a company what uh what excites you
or what uh
what makes you want to devote
yourself to that and that first and
foremost i think is about the people
there
i'm less enamored with uh specific
technologies
and more so with the team that i'll be
working with i'll
i'll let you in on what is probably not
a very big secret
when i my second job out of college was
with uh was with mercury mercury
interactive
mercury interactive was in the field
of automated software testing
when i joined i i struggled to find
something that i thought would would be
more boring than software testing in my
mind um
testing as a discipline you know it was
where the uh
programmers who couldn't hack it as as
developers would go they don't
test other people's work um and we're
going to develop software that will help
them
do their testing job better oh big deal
um
but it actually was it was a tremendous
journey first and foremost because the
company was
was amazing but also the people that i
worked with um
i have since then uh never had in one
place such a collection of great people
uh i've worked with individuals or in
other places or just as
as good but as a company i i
haven't seen it there um so going back
to the last part
it's a question of how well you do
against objectives
and i think that's actually what
attracted me to the
company where i'm currently at or just
recently started working
for indigo which
its uh mission its purpose in life is to
help
organizations turn their strategy
into focused uh execution what
uh what it attempts to solve using
ai and software as a service delivery
model is this common problem that we all
i'm sure have experienced at one point
or another in our careers
which is companies struggle to put
strategy into practice
and it's the more mature the company is
the bigger it is the longer it's been
around the harder it is to
innovate and come up with new things and
so what companies do
is they go on these management retreats
or
off-site where all the senior leaders of
the company come together
and decide here are the three most
important things we need to do
in order to uh beat the competition or
just to survive
and thrive and while you're at the
retreat
everybody is fully on board and there's
clear understanding
across all the teams of what needs to be
done and then you go back to the office
and within two to three weeks
it's all dissipated away because you got
distracted by day-to-day
tasks and putting out fires and so on
and
um we want to solve that problem
and actually hold you in certain ways
accountable to uh
here's what you said was important to
you are you actually working on those
important things and what is the impact
those things made to your uh
organization's goals i think that's
that's amazing i'm
not looking sort of at the young
entrepreneur sphere whether it's an
engineer coming out of an
of a university or out of the idf or
somebody who's creating their own
company what are some things that you
can think of from your
you know years of experience that you
would say you know i think both you know
on an emotional level
on on you know what what should be the
next step so you're mentioning that
you know your your journey was almost
half hazardous but at the same time
i believe that now as reflecting back i
think there's a clear reason as to every
decision
but what would be you know some of the
things that we should be keeping in mind
as young entrepreneurs and engineers uh
do we follow our
our gut do we follow our emotions do we
follow our intellectual curiosity
and do we follow the just the the right
people
is there even a way to know or is it all
just you know a big balagan that
every person has to sort of guess at the
end
my biggest takeaway um reflecting on my
career is that there's no right answer
there's no one formula that says do this
uh and this will work for some people
having a clear plan
and executing it every step of the way
is the way to go for other people
doing it doing things more half-half
hazardously and just making
the right decision at each point in time
works equally well that's certainly the
way
i've handled it so uh my advice would be
don't get too caught up in making a plan
if that's not the kind of person that
you are
but if you are uh very meticulous and
very planned yeah that could work too
um get regardless of which uh
approach you take i think it's helpful
to get an outsider's view uh some
go through a formal process of
mentorship and getting people who would
regularly coach them
that's certainly a way to go others have
a few trusted advisors that they would
go to in
a certain points of time when there's a
critical decision to be made
just to get an outsider's opinion or a
second pair of eyes
that works well too i want to touch on
what you said about
following your passion um
i i'm ambivalent about that on the one
hand yes
you don't want to be in a position where
you are working
at a job that you hate that you are
dread mondays to the extent where
sunday's afternoons are already uh
overshadowed by these dark clouds on the
horizons because you know that you're
going to start work
in a few hours and you hate your job you
certainly don't want to be
there but i also think that at the same
time i think the advice of
just follow your passion um
is not one that i i give my my kids i
think that
could um because we live in a real world
where you need to get a job
that supports you and supports your
family
and um while money can't buy happiness
it certainly makes
life's journey much easier and if you
don't have money and if you're
struggling to make ends meet then even
if it's
the job is your passion you're not going
to be happy so you need to find some
some sort of a happy medium between
these and
i'm certainly not a proponent of follow
your passion no matter what
i mean if your passion is yeah if your
passion is is is
um
reading philosophy that books
i think uh making a living as a
philosopher
is tough it's not not something i would
recommend
i love the idea of balance i think that
what i've noticed and what's been
bothering me about this question as well
as you know the the taking choosing like
a zero-sum
approach right you either follow your
passion or you don't but and that's not
the case and i think what you're
referring here is a balance there needs
to be a good balance
both being very intentional and
meticulous about
following things that are interesting to
you at the same time being
having this realism right and
understanding that you know it's not
necessarily
you know it's not just if you follow
your die hard passion that's you know
you have to still
it's not going to be a passion for a
long time if it doesn't help you you
know survive
and be successful in life so there needs
to be some balance and
and i think that i get inspired you know
while reading your fun fact that
you know you're it sounds like one of
your passions is cycling right and
you don't have you don't have to have a
profession in cycling or do that you
know
in your your nine to five nine to seven
to midnight job but
yeah but you can still do that intensely
quite intensively and it's fantastic you
don't
i really wanna thank you for coming here
20 minutes go by way way too fast i
really appreciate it
i have the most important question
that's still ahead of us which is the
three words that you would use to
describe yourself
um
i'm a realist i call it as i see it i
love it
i'm a realist i love it thank you very
very much
and stay safe and stay healthy thank you
very much and same to you stay
safe out there hopefully this will be
behind us soon
you